next
a lot goes into a casting decision
especially when the movie has the
potential to make a billion dollars
hello any marvel movie so it makes sense
that casting directors at the last
minute get cold feet and do a quick
switcharoo find out all of the what
could have beens with your fave stars
and how they almost weren't cast in
their iconic roles
number one chris hemsworth all in the
family fans of thor literally could not
picture anyone else playing the nordic
god with the hammer and arms
[Music]
but there's a world or an alternative
multiverse if you will where chris was
not the hemsworth they were looking for
i think my audition sucked casting lore
tells it also known as chris hemsworth
on a press cycle for thor love and
thunder that the younger hemsworth liam
made it to the top five choices for the
part however his youth got in the way
and made the casting decision about
meeting someone just like him but older
and in steps chris his literal older
brother the rest is marvel cinematic
universe history
number two sadie sink
she almost didn't run up that hill
casting for stranger things has been a
10 out of 10 job so far really everyone
gets a t-shirt with all the core cast
feeling as though they stepped out of
the 80s and on to the set but newer cast
member sadie sink almost didn't get a
chance to wander into the upside down
the all too well music video star had
the chops to be a serious lead with her
theater background she was little orphan
annie but casting had to pause before
pulling the trigger of hiring her due to
her seeming too old for her age they
thought i was gonna be too old
but i was just like no just give me give
me more material however they pushed
through and by all accounts made the
very right decision of casting her as
max according to sync the moment she
stepped on set her heights and looks
matched the other cast perfectly so no
fear of aging out of the cast
number three david harbour a-list
competition for fans of stranger things
it seems like literally no one else in
the world could play the rugged yet
lovable hopper
yep
however according to david harbour big
names were offered that part before he
ever donned the police uniform while
none of these major celebs have
confirmed that they were once offered
the part of hopper by the duffer
brothers ewan mcgregor and sam rockwell
were apparently on the list whether or
not these rumors are true it's safe to
say that audiences can breathe a sigh of
relief if the ultimate choice was harper
number four winona ryder standing up to
cancel culture while winona ryder was an
early casting choice for the creators of
stranger things the duffer brothers they
were initially met with pushback writer
for several years had been for lack of a
better word cancelled by the industry
and it may have been a risky move to
include rider in the soon to be netflix
staple and now you're asking for my help
however deals were pushed through and
wynonna ultimately landed the job fans
and critics agree that they would rather
see no one else scream cry well then
wynonna as joyce byers where's will
number five benedict cumberbatch
celebrity casting parade when it comes
to who else would have filled the shoes
of doctor strange it might be easier to
ask who wasn't asked and while
cumberbatch was offered the role and
initially had to decline due to
scheduling conflicts a long list of
a-listers were considered in tandem with
benedict and once you get a load of who
it may have been the multiverse of
options seems endless
doctor strange not master strange not mr
strange
doctor strange some actors that were
considered for the role of dr strange
were ewen mcgregor tom hardy keanu
reeves nicholas cage and joaquin phoenix
surprised the kitchen sink wasn't
included in there too
allow me to help you and while benedict
is the perfect doctor strange minds
can't help but wonder what a nicolas
cage doctor strange would have looked
like more erratic shouting for sure
number six scarlett johansson nothing
but contract woes while scarjo is a
match made in marvel heaven when
portraying black widow she very much
almost didn't don that skin-tight
costume originally the part was offered
to actress emily blunt of the devil
wears prada fame and tbh emily wanted
the part real bad however due to
contractual limitations with paramount
studios emily had to sit this one out
even though it broke her heart and while
emily still gets to kick butt and other
action movies like edge of tomorrow and
sicario here's hoping she gets to donna
cape sooner rather than later
number 7 miles teller everyone's
favorite shimmying top gun he had his
breakthrough role in the spectacular now
but there's a world in which he almost
never spectacularly got cast upon his
first audition miles felt as though he
did not embody the part of sutter but
was ultimately cast always good to have
the top of the top in your corner
number 8 daniel radcliffe most children
have to do what they're told even if
you're a child star such was the case
for harry potter himself daniel
radcliffe daniel was scouted at a night
out on the theater with his parents by
one of the producers of the harry potter
movies and while that's a truly
hollywood story the demands being asked
of the young one proved too much for
radcliffe's parents to handle upon first
offer the producers wanted to sign
daniel for all six movies and for them
to all be filmed in los angeles and
while this sounds like a true teen dream
radcliffe's parents deemed that this
would be too much of disruption for
daniel's life and turn down the audition
no no
definitely not luckily situations
changed in the initial first two movies
were to be filmed in london instead of
la therefore movie history was made by
daniel radcliffe getting the role of
literally any lifetime number nine
helena bonham carter the lestrange way
of nabbing the part everyone's favorite
eccentric almost haunted doll-like
actress seems to be a no-brainer when it
comes to casting a movie about wizards
and witches
however this was not the plan when it
came to casting bellatrix lestrange in
the harry potter franchise the original
actor offered the role was helen mccrory
unfortunately helen had to turn down the
role of a lifetime because she had a bun
in the oven
number 10 robert pattinson to emo for a
teen movie when it came to being team
edward or team jacob the choice is
pretty obvious team edward forever
however when it came to being team
robert pattinson there were some
obstacles standing in the way the odds
were definitely stacked against
pattinson considering there were over 5
000 actors seen for the part and while
several actors were considered for the
part including dave franco jamie
campbell bauer and shit's creek dustin
milligan while it must have been the
relief to finally snag the role even
during filming producers threatened to
fire patinson due to his overly emo
performance thank goodness that firing
never came to fruition because we all
know and love that overly emo vampire
just the way he is
number 11 anne hathaway if at first you
don't succeed one cannot imagine the
iconic anne hathaway not being in the
iconic devil wears prada but this was
certainly going to be the case and was
wait for it
the ninth choice to play the lead of
andy sachs the role originally being
rachel mcadams who let's be honest would
have knocked this character out of the
park home run you know but sadly rachel
had to pass on the project three times
honestly it seemed as though rachel
really really didn't want it and anne
wanted it real bad like never stopped
campaigning calling fox studios and
proving to the powers that be that she
deserved the part bad after the seal of
approval from meryl streep herself and
was in
number 12 zac efron proving his
smoldering side in the world of movies
casting teen sensation as link larkin in
the broadway musical turned movie
hairspray makes the most casting sense
in the world
however director adam shankman didn't
see it that way at all needing the
character of link to come across
smoldering and downright sexy
shankman didn't buy efron as that type
shankman claimed he came into auditions
sweet and goofy like he is in high
school musical nothing like sexy link
larkin funnily enough it took adam's
sister to make him see the star power
efron had to offer and then the part was
his 2007 was a wild time low-rise genes
were in fashion and directors thought
zac efron wouldn't be attractive enough
to play a teen heartthrob in a musical
number 13 miley cyrus making the best of
both worlds happen ludicrous to think
that miley wasn't the immediate choice
to play the girl with the best of both
worlds but such is casting considered
too small by casting agents miley did
everything she could to convince them
she was the one miley said they kind of
kicked me to the curb and i just kept
sending in takes i tried to get more
makeup higher heels to look older and it
didn't work months passed and the role
of hannah still hadn't been filled so
ever the determined miley gave it one
more shot and the part was hers
number 14 kate winslet no shrinking
violet proving that booking a role is
truly the role of a die the actor
suffered generation kate winslet almost
wasn't cast in a movie that defined a
generation that's right director james
cameron wasn't sold on the already
oscar-nominated actor claiming he wanted
a more audrey hepburn type aka tiny and
small woman winslet was determined to
book the part and apparently called
cameron and screamed you don't
understand i am rose guess that's all
the proof we need to know that kate was
the reason to not let jack on the door
conspiracy theories commence
number 15 jennifer aniston muddling her
way to the top the character that
launched 1 million hair trends rachel
from the hit nbc sitcom friends is
played to perfection by america's
sweetheart jennifer aniston anderson
however was not the primo choice for the
career defining role jennifer was
already a rising star and had been
booked on another television show
muddling through however the creators of
friends were so gung-ho on aniston that
contracts be darned they signed her
anyways and just bet on muddling through
to not make it to series safe to say
that bet was one of the safest to ever
occur in the entertainment industry hey
everybody this is rachel and another
lincoln high survivor
this has been a walk down memory lane of
who could have been and who definitely
always should have been the characters
we all know and love today which casting
decision blew your mind wide open like
comment and subscribe to the things